đoàn người ăn gú vía khi sĩ mắt năm 2018, vì nghe định thoại của các ngàn dường.
Theo con ngàn người ăn, sáng nay 1 tháng 1,
tong ngàn sạch sĩ nông, nhận được tinh bảo của Anh Tẹ Cuysê,
xin ngâm một nghỉ trái chăm bệ vý mốt, chú trên giữa bàn.
Thế tinh bài của Anh Sê, phó khóng huy dựa bụng biệt phút cùng ngay,
một số định thải lạc gọi cho Anh tự xinh là dúng,
cạnh bộ con ngàn, thân báo Anh chưa cay đặt tại khoản định xanh định từ ở mức độ hai,
có đình như anh tài đặt để thức kiện các xong dịch liên của anh đến nhanh,
nếu không tài khoản nhanh sẽ bị khó,
xong khi nhận được định thải Anh xin hòn tuần tinh tường,
lý tài khoản định xanh định từ của Anh mới tài đặt ở mức độ một một,
có hiện trong thời khoản nhanh của Anh đang có một hành tích kịp của 2 vụ trong,
chừng bị hưi trước quan học đại học.
Anh sẽ sất lâu lắng về được tài khoản của mình sẽ bị khóa,
mình đã nghe người vì đang ông tự xinh là cảnh bộ con ngàn,
hướng sẽ đặt tại khoản định xanh định từ ở mức độ hai,
có được người đại đe nghị của các các thông tin mà số định giang ngày tháng 5 sinh
số thời khoản nhanh mà ông tài tình,
số khi thông các thông tin ở trên Anh xe thích hiện
cho 1 bộ số tiên năm 2019 trong thời khoản của mình đã không tảnh mà bây,
nghe lực tức anh đã đến các khoản công an trình báo,
sau khi tích nhận trình báo khoản xe,
công an sạch sĩ đồng đã chân ăn thình thần,
có sạch thích sạch anh đã bị đối tượng số lừa đạo trính bởi tài sản.
Đông thời hướng sẽ đăng thử thiện các mức sách mình
phó hợp với anh hàng nhằm ngăn trạch sau dịch đến chưa cùng ngày,
Anh xe đánh nhận hạch toàn bộ số tiên năm 2019.